- When we were
dominating the debate
on critical race theory in late
2020, and then really 2021,
you saw the left retreat
from these issues.
All of a sudden, Robin DiAngelo
was nowhere to be found.
Ibram Kendi was you
know, on the defensive.
And then you saw this
shift in the debate
when those same
teachers and districts
that had been pushing
critical race theory in 2021,
started really doubling
down on, especially trans,
non-binary and queer
identity formations
as the new thing, the new
trend, the new you know,
current thing, with
capital C and capital T.
And they thought that they
could really just shift
the debate and win
on these grounds.
And so in a sense,
they're complimentary.
They can play three-card
monte with these two ideas.
But I think there's
also a deeper nexus
or connection between the two.
You know, students at the
elementary school level,
high school level, you
know, they can be shamed.
They can be told that
their racial category,
you know, let's say for example,
white students are told that
they have white privilege,
white fragility, unconscious
white racial superiority.
They're part of the
systemically racist society
by virtue of their ancestry.
But that doesn't really, in
some ways, help tremendously.
You can't change your race.
They can't do anything about it
at the level of
their own identity.
But these sexual
identities offer an escape
from the guilt and
shame that was instilled
on the critical race
theory narrative.
And they offer an escape,
so you get, in some cases,
you know, I talk to teachers
that say, "yeah," you know,
"40% of my white female
students in middle school
now identify as non-binary,
transgender, et cetera."
And so it gives them an
avenue for participation,
not just at the
level of ideology,
but the deeper
level of identity.
And so in some ways,
critical race theory
serves to push people into
some of these constructs
as an avenue out.
(upbeat music)
- I am Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is a senior fellow at
the Manhattan Institute,
and author of the
brand new book,
"America's Cultural Revolution:
How the Radical Left
Conquered Everything."
Chris Rufo, my friend, welcome
back to "The Rubin Report."
- It's great to be with you.
- Chris, did they
conquer everything?
Everything Chris?
- Yeah, I mean, obviously,
there's a little bit
of fun and hyperbole.
Certainly, they haven't
conquered your studio
or my studio, even though
(Dave laughs)
they might be banging down
the door at any minute.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But in all seriousness,
they really did.
I mean, I think that's what
we really learned in 2020.
All of a sudden people
looked around and they saw
that all of their institutions
had been conquered
by the ideologies of the left,
whether it's critical race
theory, radical gender ideology,
so-called diversity,
equity, and inclusion.
All of our private
companies were really riding
that BLM line.
And so many Americans
looked around
and said, well, what happened?
How did this suddenly occur?
That all of these
neo-Marxist ideologies
seemed to be at the forefront
of all of our institutions?
And the reason I wrote this
book was to answer that question
and to dig deep
into the history,
going back more
than a half century,
explaining how this happened,
what is going on
with our institutions
and how we can fight back.
- All right, so I wanna
dive into all of that.
And clearly, my audience
knows an awful lot about it
and has tracked you
for quite some time.
You've been on the
show a million times.
But for somebody
that's watching this,
that is not too
familiar with your work,
how did you get involved
in this whole thing?
Because you've become
sort of the center
of fighting back against this.
- That's right, it
really all started
with my investigative reporting
for "City Journal" magazine.
I looked at some training
programs in the summer of 2020.
Sources around the country
were sending me documents
from their DEI programs.
Talking about systemic racism,
white privilege,
white fragility,
segregating employees
on the basis of race
and shaming some employees
and praising other employees
based on their ancestry.
And this reporting really
exploded in the season of 2020.
And I identified
that the ideology
that was driving this
kind of programming
was critical race theory.
I went on "Tucker," when
he was still on Fox News,
and asked President Trump
to sign an executive order
abolishing CRT trainings
from the Federal Government.
He did so, and that
really launched
this whole line of reporting,
this line of activism,
and really, this line of
inquiry to say, you know,
in a democracy, we think
that majority opinion
should be translated in
our public institutions.
That's not the
case, for example,
when schools are
pushing CRT on kids,
over and against the best wishes
and the desires of parents.
And so while I made my
name, in a certain sense,
as an activist, as a
muckraking reporter,
what I wanted to do was
also give those readers
a chance to go deeper, a
chance to really understand
what's happening
under the surface,
what is the genealogy
of these ideas.
And really, go beyond
the quick hit, you know,
headlines and news bites,
and giving something
very substantive
so that those of us on the right
or in the center or
even the center-left,
can be armed with all the
information that we need
in order to start fighting
back against these ideologies,
both at an intellectual level,
but also at a political level.
- Alright, so let's do some
101 for some of the people
that are just catching
up on this stuff.
Can you define
critical race theory?
- Sure, critical race theory
is an academic discipline
that holds that the United
States is a fundamentally
and systemically racist country.
And that all of our
institutions, from
our legal system
to our constitution, even to
the Civil Rights Act itself,
are smoke screens
that preach the values
of liberty and freedom,
but in reality,
serve to uphold a system
of naked racial domination.
And so it's this idea that
any disparity in outcomes
can be traced back
to a hidden, a secret
or an invisible racist system.
That the critical
race theorists believe
they're privileged in
their ability to ferret out
all of these hidden racisms.
And so critical
race theory though,
is the ideology at
the tip of the spear,
but it traces back
decades upon decades,
back to neo-Marxist ideology,
that's really the
very basis of this.
And so while critical race
theory was hotly debated
in the headlines for
a number of years,
we have to understand that in
order to really root it out,
we have to go even a
further step deeper.
- So when we had that
like, three month blip,
probably about a
year and a half ago,
where everybody in
mainstream media kept saying,
"oh, they don't teach critical
race theory in schools.
They don't teach it in schools."
And yet every day,
those of us that live,
at least partially online,
we would see, you know,
curriculum that
was getting leaked.
We'd see teachers, you
know, caught on the DL,
admitting they're teaching
it, et cetera, et cetera.
What was that like for you?
Because it wasn't necessarily
that they were handing
a book to the
children that said,
this is critical race theory,
but they were figuring out
other ways to leak the ideas
that you just expressed,
into all of the stuff
that they've been teaching.
- Yeah, I mean, it
was unbelievable
because I was
publishing these stories
with leaked
curriculum documents.
I was always posting the
original source materials,
sometimes hundreds of
pages of materials.
And then even in
states like California,
Washington, and Illinois,
they were putting critical
race theory, explicitly,
in their state-mandated
curriculum.
But for months, the left
said critical race theory
doesn't exist, it's a boogeyman,
it's a kind of phenomenon
of a fevered
right-wing imagination.
And in all of these
pieces attacking me,
they never once addressed the
specifics of my reporting,
where I put it in very
clear, black and white,
this is what they're teaching,
these are the principles
of critical race theory.
This is the intention
of these lessons.
And so they tried to maintain
that posture for a long time,
that critical race
theory doesn't exist.
But what happened is that
we hit them every day
with more facts, more evidence,
more concrete documentation.
So that position slowly
became untenable.
And even the more honest
and writers and journalists
on the left started to
say, well, you know,
critical race theory
is in the curriculum.
Maybe it's not labeled
critical race theory,
but certainly the
principles are at play here.
And so there was a kind of
concession for a little bit.
And then it flipped, following
the really natural script
that we've seen over and over.
Then they started saying, yeah,
there is critical
race theory and good,
we want critical race
theory in the curriculum.
So you saw even the
largest teachers union
in the United States
pass a resolution saying
that we want to have
critical race theory
in all 14,000 local
school districts.
You know, they said it
very explicitly by name,
we love CRT, we
want CRT everywhere.
And then the media started
defending critical race theory.
But there was one thing
that was really interesting,
is that parents, throughout
this whole debate,
throughout this whole subterfuge
and really, manipulation
on behalf of the media,
they knew what was happening.
And that's why they showed
up at school board meetings.
That's why they were protesting,
that's why they were demanding
changes to the curriculum
because they saw not
just my reporting,
but what was happening in
their local communities,
what kids were bringing
home in their backpacks
every day after school.
And they said, wait a minute.
We do not want racial
scapegoating in our curriculum.
We do not want our
kids being judged
as avatars of racial categories,
and we do not want to be
taught a false history
of the United States
that condemns it
as a racist society
through and through.
And so you know, that was
the arc of the debate.
And I think ultimately, whether
you look at public opinion,
whether you look at legislation,
whether you look
at even the posture
of our opponents on the left,
I think we resoundingly,
won that debate over
the course of that year
or two-year period.
- Can you talk about
how this is connected
to all of the gender stuff,
so it's not just race stuff?
Because when you talk
about the parents,
I think the thing that
lit the parents on fire,
they were pissed, to a
degree, about the race stuff.
But to me, it was
the gender ideology
and then the election
of Youngkin in Virginia,
that that lit that on fire.
And then we'll talk a bit more
about Disney and DeSantis,
because you had something
to do with that as well.
But how the gender piece of
this is connected, oddly,
to the race piece of this.
- Yeah, I mean, look, if
you look back 50 years
at left-wing ideology,
once they abandoned
the orthodox Marxist
idea of class conflict.
So the two great
categories are, you know,
the bourgeoisie and
the proletariat,
or the capitalist class
and the working class.
That stopped working by
the mid 20th century.
And left-wing intellectuals
were looking for
other soft spots,
other lines of attack,
and they settled on race
and sex or race and gender.
And that was the
new formulation.
And so when we were
dominating the debate
on critical race theory in late
2020, and then really 2021,
you saw the left retreat
from these issues.
All of a sudden, Robin DiAngelo
was nowhere to be found.
Ibram Kendi was, you
know, on the defensive.
And then you saw this
shift in the debate
when those same
teachers and districts
that had been pushing
critical race theory in 2021,
started really doubling
down on, especially,
trans, non-binary and
queer identity formations
as the new thing, the new
trend, the new, you know,
current thing, with
capital C and capital T.
And they thought that
they could really,
just shift the debate
and win on these grounds.
And so in a sense,
they're complimentary.
They can play three-card
monte with these two ideas.
But I think there's
also a deeper nexus
or connection between the two.
You know, students at the
elementary school level,
high school level, you
know, they can be shamed.
They can be told that their
racial category, you know,
let's say for example,
white students are told
that they have white privilege,
white fragility, unconscious
white racial superiority.
They're part of the
systemically racist society
by virtue of their ancestry.
But that doesn't really, in
some ways, help tremendously.
You can't change your race.
They can't do anything
about it at the level
of their own identity.
But these sexual
identities offer an escape
from the guilt and
shame that was instilled
on the critical race
theory narrative,
and they offer an escape.
So you get, in some cases,
you know, I talk to teachers
that say, "yeah," you know,
"40% of my white female
students in middle school now,
identify as non-binary, queer,
transgender, et cetera."
And so it gives them an
avenue for participation,
not just at the
level of ideology,
but the deeper
level of identity.
And so in some ways,
critical race theory serves
to push people into
some of these constructs
as an avenue out.
And I think that we're
seeing that in many places.
And in some ways, it's actually
been a harder debate to win.
I think that with CRT we had
a very successful debate.
And I think that with gender;
and I'd be curious to
hear your perspective,
and sexuality, we're still
in a very kind of
amorphous situation
where it's not quite clear
which side is winning.
It's not quite queer,
(stammers) quite clear, (laughs)
(Dave laughs)
both of those apply,
but it's not quite queer
or clear, you know,
where this debate is heading.
I think there's a
stalemate in some sense,
and I'm not sure, what's
your interpretation
of where we are today?
- Yeah, well,
I mean, one of the
things that, you know,
I had Douglas
Murray on last week
and that we've talked
about for quite some time,
is that the Ls and
the Gs and the Bs,
which are a sexuality,
not a sexual identity,
really need to
separate from the Ts.
I am not denying, or
gay people, let's say,
are not denying biology.
They are not trying to
force a young person
to alter their body in a way
that is not congruent
with reality.
Now, you could have a
personal religious belief
on homosexuality.
Personally, I think that's fine,
as long as you're not
trying to legislate it.
But there's a
fundamental difference
between sexuality
and sexual identity,
and that sort of blurring
of reality is the problem.
So as I often say, and I'm sure
you've said something similar,
there's no group
that is more anti-LGB
than the Ts, and the Ts,
there's also no group
that is more
anti-female than the Ts,
who now, want biological
men to beat women in sports.
So I think the confluence
or the combination
of those letters has been
really, really dangerous
for gay people in general.
- Yeah, that's interesting.
I do wonder too, I think that
there's something happening
on the political
right where, you know,
there was a kind of a
concession in a sense,
on the political right.
The moral majority of
the 1980s and 1990s
has really disappeared
as a political force.
You don't see anything
analogous to the Ralph Reeds
or the Pat Robertsons, you
know, the "700 Club" guys.
That generation of
social conservative,
Christian Conservatives has,
I think, really, you know,
in some cases that
literally died off,
but in other cases just
kind of disappeared
as a political force.
There was a period I think,
where there was a kind of truce
on some of these social issues.
And so it's been
interesting to watch
the right start to
change a little bit.
And I think what's
really led to this,
and I think, it's
a disastrous move
on behalf of the radical
gender activists,
is to actually say now, hey,
we're gonna come into
institutions, come into schools
and then push, not
just, you know,
tolerance of you know,
of gay sexuality.
So saying, hey, there
are gay kids in schools.
They should be, you
know, treated equally
as everyone else.
They shouldn't be
bullied, shamed,
or humiliated because
of their sexuality.
They should be brought
into the wider community.
I think that virtually
everyone supports
that kind of basic
dignity and tolerance.
But what we're seeing
now, in schools,
is that they're saying,
they're pushing it
as an ideology saying, you
know, not just transgender
or transsexuality, which is,
you know, in its modern sense,
roughly 100 years old,
but they're actually now,
inventing, you know,
genders and sexualities
of, you know,
non-binary, two-spirit,
all of these boutique
identities that in a real sense,
are fake categories.
And they're pushing
them onto kids
and they're really desiring
and really using kids,
that are impressionable,
as pawns in a greater
political game.
And I think that's what people
are really revolting against.
They're saying,
hey, wait a minute,
you have a policy where
you can secretly transition
my child into a
non-binary, they, them,
and then push the
identity into a political
activist posture without
even notifying me,
as the parent, is so
deeply manipulative.
And I think that, you
know, it is, I hope,
a miscalculation on
behalf of these activists
because I just don't
think that that can stand
over the long term.
A lot of people on the
right are uncomfortable
talking about these issues.
Uncomfortable, you know,
activating against them.
But as we've seen with
all the detransitioners,
we see with these
horror stories,
it's untenable in
the medium term.
And so I think, that
while the debate might be
a bit in kind of
a stalemate now,
I think, that ultimately,
it's got to shift,
it's got to go
back to the center.
- Yeah, well, you're right
about what a damn shame it is,
because for, you're
right, the moral majority,
the Rick Santorums,
Mike Huckabee types,
they've moved on
from these things.
Trump ran, first term
around, you know,
first term, as pro-gay
marriage, people put it to bed.
And then they've just
rehashed all of this stuff.
And the average
gay person really,
wants nothing to do with it.
But you know, the activist class
always needs something to do.
But to that point, you know,
as we've exited Gay Pride month,
and thankfully, we can go
back to shame, hallelujah.
You know, there were so many,
that ridiculous flag that
once was the rainbow,
that included everything.
But now they've
politicized the rainbow
with this triangle and
the circle and the brown
and the whole thing.
The fact that they're putting
that up at the White House,
when you see that up
at the White House,
equal with the American flag,
which actually might be a
violation of the Constitution,
or when you see that hanging
outside of the Canadian
Prime Minister's office,
I think most people don't
realize it's a political flag.
People think, oh, it's
just celebrating sexuality,
but it's actually
political in nature.
That's really what
you're saying.
- Yeah, 100%, I mean, it
is a political movement,
and it's a political movement
with its own iconography,
with its own, you know, kind
of propaganda messaging.
And it's like any other
political movement,
it has its set of symbols.
And certainly, what I
think of, when Biden hung
the Progress Pride Flag,
I guess it's called now,
the one with all the
different shapes.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Look, it's a basic
political patronage move.
Biden knows where the energy
is on the activist part
of his political base.
He knows that this is
a very important part
of his coalition.
And he is essentially,
rewarding the activists
within that coalition
with this symbolic display
and kind of White
House ceremony.
You know, I think
that in a sense,
it's kind of normal
patronage politics.
And so that's how I view that.
And Biden is, you know,
for all of his faults
and for all of his
seeming, you know,
kind of slow kind of mental
capacities as he ages,
he knows which way
the wind is blowing.
He knows where the
Democratic Coalition is.
And I think that it
shows really, the power
of that activist narrative,
the power of that
activist apparatus,
that they get their
flag hung up, you know,
where really, only kind
of the American flag
or the national flag should
be hanging, in my opinion.
And I think that the
debate about flags
and symbols is really important.
The things that we
elevate symbolically,
are the things that we value
in a more human
and meaningful way.
And so we should be quite
careful and quite deliberate
and have really, an open debate
about what kind of symbols
that we put in places
of national prominence.
And certainly, in a
public school, you know,
you couldn't hang a crucifix
at the top of the public
school, a religious symbol.
You know, you couldn't
hang a, you know,
partisan political
flag at the top
of a public school classroom.
And so I think that
it's very interesting
that the Pride and
Progress Pride Flag
are given an exemption
for restrictions
on religious and political
symbolism in classrooms.
It's a pretty sophisticated
reason that that is the case.
They've been very good
at kind of laundering
the political message that
is the essence of this,
with kind of vague, tolerant,
diversity, equity, inclusion,
surface level messaging that
allows it to be displayed
in places where the
kind of analogous flags
of any other political
or religious movement
would not be allowed,
would not even really
be contemplated.
- Right, well, they say
it's all about inclusivity,
but that flag does
not include me.
It doesn't include Douglas
Murray or Peter Thiel
or Spencer Klavan, or
the litany, Rick Grenell,
or plenty of other gay people.
But let's move on for a sec,
because one of the other
things that sort of caught fire
in the last year, was the
war that DeSantis went at
with Disney, and you
were a piece of that
at a couple different fronts.
But am I correct, you
were the one that leaked
the original Disney
videos, right?
- Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, I have a
source inside Disney,
actually, multiple
sources inside Disney.
I had reported on their
critical race theory
employee training
program in 2020,
and then, or in 2021 rather.
And in 2022, as the Disney
fight was brewing with DeSantis,
one of my sources
leaked me these really,
incredible videos from
inside the company,
as well as some other
supporting documents,
that kicked it off.
And even Governor DeSantis,
at the bill signing,
stripping Disney of
its special privileges,
he said during the ceremony,
he said, "You know,
if Rufo hadn't
leaked these videos,
I don't know if
we'd even be here."
That was really, a pivotal
moment in this fight.
And it's an important fight
because it not only marks
a fight about gender
ideology in schools;
you'll remember that that's
what this was all about,
the Parental Rights
and Education Act.
But it also marks a shift
on the political right
against this libertarian
corporatist, you know,
we can call it a neoliberal
tendency on the political right,
where the corporations
are always right.
We never fight
with corporations.
We never get crosswise
with the Fortune 100.
DeSantis changed that
very dramatically.
And although I
think it, you know,
it kind of enraged libertarians,
I think most Conservatives are
now thinking, wait a minute,
these companies are not just
creating products and services,
you know, adding to the GDP,
but they're actually
waging ideological fights.
They're wading into
partisan cultural fights.
And they're now, crosswise
with Conservative voters.
And we need to have
political leaders
that are willing to stand up,
not just to our traditional
opponents on the left,
but even these new opponents
within our traditional coalition
that have now, deviated from
support of the political right
and waded into the culture war
on behalf of the cultural left.
- Right, so when that happened,
and then DeSantis decides
to use state power
to push back against
it, were you surprised
to see some of the, you know,
whether we wanna call 'em
Neoliberals or
fake Conservatives,
you know, guys like Mike Pence,
oh this is too much
government power.
Nikki Haley, too much
government power,
when finally, a Conservative
was actually doing something
about the things that they're
always complaining about?
- Yeah, I mean, I
wasn't surprised,
but I was certainly,
frustrated and disappointed
because they're just repeating
this brain dead script
that has been programmed
in them since the 1980s.
But it's not the 1980s anymore.
And while that was
probably the right ideology
or philosophy or
policy for the time,
things have shifted a bit.
And even on their
own terms, though,
I argue that with libertarians
all the time on this,
and then sometimes they concede.
I say, "wait a minute, even
on libertarian grounds,
I think DeSantis did
the right thing."
And they say, "What?
He interfered with a private
company, what do you mean?"
I say, "Well, look at it."
Disney, in decades before
DeSantis was in office,
used their economic power,
used their lobbying power,
and used their cultural power
to extract special privileges
from the state of Florida.
They had special tax structure,
special regulatory structure,
special real estate structure.
You know, they had
the right to create
their own nuclear power
plant at some point,
through the kind
of sweetheart deals
they'd negotiated
with the state.
And these are
special privileges,
crony capitalist privileges-
- Right.
- That none of their competitors
and none of the other
private companies had.
And in fact, DeSantis didn't-
- SeaWorld,
does it have a nuke?
- SeaWorld does not have nukes,
although maybe it should,
you know, and send them
(Dave laughs)
to the Ukraine or
something, I don't know.
But you know, none of
the other companies
had these privilege, so in fact,
DeSantis was doing nothing
but level the playing field
so that Disney had to
compete with all the others.
And it created actually,
a more free market
and a less crony
capitalist system.
And of course, then
they turn very silent
and they say, uh oh,
I can't fall back on
my ideology anymore.
You know, Ayn Rand is
somewhere in the corner,
you know, crying.
(Dave laughs)
You know, we
actually have to have
a substantive
debate about culture
and Libertarians
are very nervous.
They want to be accepted
by the left on culture.
But what I think it really
shows, is that on all grounds,
except for the simple
friend-enemy grounds,
if you're, you
know, on the left,
I think that his move was
defensible on all grounds.
And not just defensible
on all grounds,
but really, put the priorities
in the correct rank order.
It said, look, protecting the
flourishing of our society
and of our kids and of our
families is more important
than protecting
corporate interests.
To me, that is the fundamental.
America is about the
protection of life,
liberty and the
pursuit of happiness.
And our economy
and our companies
should all be
thought of as means,
in order to achieve the
end, of human happiness.
So I think DeSantis
is in the right,
both, looking at our
founding principles,
looking at libertarian
principles,
and looking at what
might be considered
social conservative principles.
- So as long as we're
talking about DeSantis
doing some stuff
right-related to this,
I think one of the
other institutions
that's done some
stuff right lately,
obviously, is the Supreme Court.
I take it, you are
pretty happy about
the reversal of this affirmative
action decision at Harvard.
And if you wanna
talk about, you know,
what you're doing
here in Florida,
that would be fine as well.
But that basically, we
are removing some of this,
what some might call,
structural or systemic racism
from the system.
- Yeah, that's right.
I think this is a huge ruling,
although it's
certainly not enough.
I'd like to see some
other precedents
such as Griggs versus Duke
Power Company overturned.
You know, we have to get to-
- What is that one?
- Sure, it's what
really established
the notion of disparate impact.
So if a policy or a
system is neutral,
it doesn't favor one
racial group or another,
but it creates
disparate outcomes.
You can read racism into
that, that could be deemed
illegal discrimination.
And so to say, for example,
that elderly Asian females
are incarcerated at a
lower rate than, you know,
young white males
or young Black males
or young Latino males, you know,
you could read into that saying,
oh, that's a disparate
outcome and therefore racist.
We have to interrogate it.
I think we have to get
to, on the other hand,
a system of colorblind
equality, very simple.
We treat you as an individual,
equally under the
law with due process.
We don't discriminate
against you on cause
of your race or ancestry,
but you're actually
put into our system
and you'll be judged
on your individual merit.
That is the only kind of
system that can be successful
at the kind of scale that
we have with, you know,
more than 300 million
people in our country.
You can't treat
people as reflections
of a racial group or as
symbols of a racial group.
You have to treat
people equally.
And so I think,
we're getting there
and we're getting there slowly.
The Supreme Court is quite
a big help on this path,
but we have to
really, push further.
I want everyone to feel that
they're given a fair shot,
that they're treated equally,
and that their outcomes
in life are of course,
dependent on where they
came from, their origins,
but also dependent on their
hard work and fair treatment.
So that what people earn,
they really feel like
that they have earned it
through their own efforts.
They haven't been punished
or rewarded on anything else
besides their own efforts,
their own contributions.
- What do you do, you
think, with the people
that use every positive thing
that comes out of the system
as proof of the
system's failure?
In other words, so we
get a good decision,
let's say that you
and I are agreeing,
from the Supreme Court
on affirmative action.
But then if you watch
MSNBC, or you watch CNN,
you listen to AOC
or Elizabeth Warren
or Kamala Harris or Joe
Biden, for all of them
it was proof that the
court is corrupted.
Thus proof, we could
probably take this back
to critical race theory,
proof that the system itself
is designed against the people.
That seems like an
intractable problem,
that every time we try
to free the people more,
that the certain
set of activists,
which now includes
people literally,
like the president
of the United States,
use that decision to
undermine the system itself.
- Yeah, I mean, I think
it's a dangerous game
that they're playing.
They interpret every
political loss for them,
as evidence of
corruption, racism,
then that justifies the
need to abolish the system,
reform the system,
pack the courts.
And so it's a circularly
self-reinforcing argument.
Every time they win,
it's evidence of the
virtue of their ideas.
Every time they lose
it's evidence of the
corruption of their enemies.
And to a certain extent,
all politics is like this.
You know, certainly, many
people on the political right,
and many people on the
political left share
in that mode of thinking.
It's a basic partisan,
reflexive thinking.
However, we really
have to, in this case,
on the political right, we
really have to shift the debate
to the substance and the merit.
One thing too, that
was totally lost
in the Supreme Court
decision, is that, you know,
they were saying, oh, this is
evidence of white supremacy.
But the plaintiffs in
the Supreme Court case
were Asian Americans, you know?
(Dave laughs)
That was like, totally lost
in all of the reporting.
- Asians are the new
white supremacists,
dude, come on.
- Yeah, exactly.
The Asian white supremacists,
the Chinese immigrant
white supremacists.
I mean, you know, so
we have to really,
what I found most effective
in all of my debates
and narrative, kind of
warfare with the left
is that the more
you can stick to
the very specific, concrete,
tangible elements of the story,
the more that you can
make a persuasive case
that is substantive, that
sticks to reported matter
or sticks to the real
concrete narrative,
the more likelihood
we have to win.
We did it on
critical race theory.
I think we're doing it
slowly, you know, on gender.
And I think we can
also do it on policies
like affirmative action,
where, by the way,
Americans of all
racial backgrounds,
white, Black, Latino,
Asian, all those,
the major racial groups,
oppose affirmative action.
And so we have to take
that public sentiment,
we have to reinforce it
with a political narrative
and substantive reporting
and court cases, et cetera,
and then start to actually say,
you know what, we're
gonna take this momentum.
We're gonna take all of this
goodwill and public support
and start to change the system.
And look, Republicans
have been very wary
of any reforms to our
civil rights bureaucracy
in the United States.
It's time that we start
pushing in that direction.
We have to reform the
Civil Rights Act of 1991,
which codifies disparate impact
analysis into federal law.
We have to move beyond that and
reform our civil rights law,
and in some ways, really
strengthen our civil rights law
in order to ensure full
colorblind equality
for everyone in our country.
- What do you think about the
idea that some states now,
will just continue
to do it right,
and some states will
continue to do it wrong?
So as you know, I very
publicly left Cali for Florida.
I feel like I live in a
different country here.
I mean, the set of
values in this state
are 180 different than
they were in Cali.
Cali is continuing
to go down that road.
Florida is stopping that.
Tennessee, let's say Texas,
more in line with us.
New York, Connecticut,
Jersey, going down that road.
Do you sense that it will
just continue to go that way?
And also that's partly because
of the migration of people,
where the blues
are gonna get bluer
and the reds are
gonna get redder,
and does it even
matter, I guess?
- Yeah, I mean, it appears
that that is the trend,
and I anticipate that
the trend will continue.
But I actually think
that, in a larger sense,
a structural sense,
that that's good.
That's exactly how our
government was intended to be.
We were intended to
be a federalist system
with states that can pursue
very different visions
of governance, very
different sets of values
that they orient
as their kind of
hierarchy of values, let's say.
And so, in a sense, I like
to see that California
and Florida and
Idaho and New York
are pursuing very different
visions of government.
It gives the citizens of
every state the ability
to look at what's happening,
to judge and compare,
to decide what they want.
And they can either fight and
advocate within their states,
or they can move to another
state that's more friendly.
This is actually good.
But there's one big caveat,
states such as California,
should not be allowed
to violate federal law,
and should not be
allowed to violate
the principles of
our constitution.
And so when states
like California,
I recently exposed a
UC Berkeley Law dean,
saying that even though
affirmative action is illegal
in the state of California,
we do it secretly,
and this is how we do it.
- Yep.
- That's not just a policy
that California can
have or not have.
That's a violation of
the 14th Amendment.
And as the law
professor, you know,
Dean Chemerinsky
should know this.
But we should be cracking
down at the federal level
for any kind of violation
of the constitution,
while giving states
the latitude to pursue
their own vision in their
other state policies.
And so, look, I live
in Washington state,
which has its advantages
and disadvantages.
I spend a lot of time in your
neck of the woods, in Florida.
I see the difference.
I'm holding out strong
here, but I certainly,
appreciate the fact that
states like Florida, Texas,
Idaho, Tennessee, are
pursuing a different path
and are doing some
really good things.
- What's the school that you're
working on here in Florida?
Is it New School?
No, it's Florida-
- That's right, the
New College of Florida.
- New College. Sorry, yeah.
- Yeah, so New College of
Florida is a perfect example.
Governor DeSantis appointed
a group of trustees,
including me, to take over
this college, to reform it.
To abolish their
DEI bureaucracy,
to install principles
of colorblind equality,
to hire new faculty
with expertise
in the classical liberal arts,
and to give the college
a renewed mission
of pursuing the classical
liberal arts education,
which kind of
paradoxically, is now coded
as a Conservative education
because it's really, been-
- It's my life
story right there.
- Disappeared from all
of our institutions
in the last few decades.
And so look, this
is gonna be a home
for a wide diversity of opinion,
and we're actively
recruiting scholars
aligned with the
classical liberal mission.
And so we're hoping to
announce some new professors.
I think some of the
people that maybe,
you might be excited about,
are currently in the mix
for the professorships
at the New College.
And we're going to be
transforming this institution,
that is not just important
for the campus itself,
but it's important
because it's a model
for all other red state
governors and legislators
and citizens to say, you
don't have to put up with,
you know, "America's
Cultural Revolution."
You don't have to put up
with all of your institution
being captured by
left-wing ideologues.
There is now a playbook for
retaking the institutions,
reforming the institutions,
and reorienting the institutions
towards your values.
- I got one more for you, Rufo.
We're posting this same week
that the book is coming out.
I have no doubt that it
is gonna do extremely well
and that it will
also be left off
the New York Times Best Seller,
I hate to tell you,
that's how it works.
But I wonder, just in
terms of media strategy,
I know you're willing to
go into the lions' den
and go after these guys.
Are you willing to go
into MSNBC and go to CNN,
and go to, say the "New York
Times" board over there,
and all of those things?
You're not gonna get the invites
and they're also not
gonna respond to you,
but just for the record, so
that once it's all out there.
- (laughs) Yeah, of
course I am, I love it.
I've not only stated
publicly, on Twitter,
that I'm open to
interviews and stories
and media appearances
with all of my critics,
but I've actually reached out,
my team has reached
out proactively to
all of those outlets.
And I will say, and this
is a point of optimism,
I think you'll be
happy about this,
I'm sensing a bit of a shift.
I've actually got a lot
of response from people at
everywhere, from
"Jacobin" to MSNBC,
to the "New York Times,"
to the "New Yorker."
They're starting to reengage.
And so I think you'll see-
- But are they putting you on?
Are you gonna be on MSNBC
to talk about this book?
- MSNBC is the one that has
not responded unfortunately,
but a lot of the print
publications on the left
have responded, they might
engage with interviews,
they might engage with podcasts,
they might engage with
reviews of the book.
And so I really hope that
the book, which look,
I think, a lot of
center-left audiences
are gonna read this
and say, "oh wow,
I heard that Rufo is a, you
know, right-wing fanatic,
but actually, his
book is totally right.
I agree with it."
I think we might see the
beginnings of a reengagement,
now that the kind of
George Floyd hysteria
has started to die down.
I sense that the left is
maybe willing to start
coming back to the table and
start engaging in debate.
I hope that the book launches
that, accelerates that trend.
I hope that not only
Conservative readers
appreciate it,
but also center and
even center-left
readers appreciate it.
I really want it
to be a focal point
for reengaging in
this conversation.
At the end of the day,
we're one country.
We all have to live here,
and we'll all be much better off
if we can engage substantively
with one another.
And I hope this book
contributes to that process.
- The book is "America's
Cultural Revolution."
And if they come, look,
you've even got a copy.
You truly are a
professional, my friend.
If they come for
you in Washington,
you're always welcome in
the free state of Florida.
- Thank you.
- Good seeing you, man.
- You too.
(gently upbeat music)
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.